[音楽]
こんにちははじめ社長です
健介さん
聞いてますか
若者のロナ子供の夢その全てをの可能性を
備えた
史上最高の施設皆さんご存知でしょうか
ゲームセンター今日は台頭ステーション
池袋西口店さんにお邪魔しております
よろしくお願いしますそしてこの超大型
店舗のゲームセンターなんと
クレーンゲームが100台あります
いやすごいよ100台もう本当にお母さん
とかフィギュアぬいぐるみもう最近人気の
美少女アニメとか東京リベンジャーズとか
も何でもあるんですけどもマジで大きくて
ここがそして今日私何をしたいかと言い
ますと100台あるやん
全部取るのに何時間かかるの
俺も怖いんですよ例えばここにあると思う
んですけどもクレーンゲームってこれで1
日1台じゃんこのほら
機嫌じゃないですよ
はい別ですけどもこれ1台なのでどっちに
しろ100台なんですけどこれはすると僕
純粋に頭がおかしいなと思ったのでこの1
台の中のどっちかを1個取ればクリアそれ
を100台分やっていくのにだいたい何
時間かかるかそして何円かかるかは
ちょっと検証していきたいと思います
ちょっと気にならないゲームセンター全部
取ろうそれぐらいかかるかっていうやばい
それ2つ分気になる方がいたら純粋に時間
を2倍してくれればそれが時間になるんで
とりあえずこの1台の中の1個取るを
100台にするのにどれくらいかかるか
検証していきたいと思います
[音楽]
はいというわけで早速やっていきましょう
一応今回ね軍資金として30万円準備し
ましたでも単純計算さ100台でしょ1台
100円ずつかかって
奇跡的に1発ずつ取れても1万円かかる
からまあ妥当な気がするんですよね
30万円両替してきます
[音楽]
ので行きたいと思いますどれにしてやろう
かなはい喉乾いたのでジュース行きますえ
秒で取っていい
行きます
じゃあ
やばいやばいはいはい来た来たここの
レモンスパークリングワンパン
なるほどこういうのサクッてやばいから
はい
スイカをくれたら
最初200円で行けたのはマジででかい
です1個目ゲットです
[音楽]
か200円で1台いけたバタークッキー
食べたかったんですけどこれで1台なので
この台はクリアです次行きましょう
いやいやもうもうなんか
値段の相場で
難易度がわかる行きますね
はいこれもう一発じゃない
うわぁ
止めればいいってわかる
決めます
さすがにいいんじゃないど真ん中
貫いたでしょうありがとうございます
チョコバットゲットだぜいや500円
ぐらいかかったかな3台目行きます
モンスター行きましょうかちょっと飲み物
買っときたいよね行きますえこんなんもう
倒してくださいと言ってるような傾いて
ないならこっち側
1回目は大体様子見2回目で決めれば
大丈夫です
はいはいどうでしょうどうでしょう
[音楽]
この方のケーいけそうじゃないもんねはい
行きますね
やりすぎたか
見せかけて
あれ戻っちゃったはいもうこいつも狙って
ください
大変なことが起きた
[音楽]
はい隙間
どうだ
うわ思ってー
お母さんモンスターの値段じゃなくなって
きてるよ
大丈夫だよな
プライスですって考えれば
いや妄想良くなったな
そっちになっちゃったやった
何が起きたよ
これを狙ってましたお前と飲みたくてな
なんかこの分かるこの隙間から落ちちゃっ
たって感じですここだけが落とすわけだよ
ねこのアウトから戻せるよっていう感じか
なあーなるほどねこれ多分相当値段高い
ですけどちょっと飲んでみていいですか
[音楽]
4代目ですポッキーとキットカットこれは
結構選ぶのがポイントでキットカットのが
短いんですよこのここが長さが長いので
短いキットカットいきますいきます
[音楽]
やりすぎたやばい
やりすぎた
地獄のような下手くそ
どうでしょうかどう待って待って待って
待って待ってそれやばいぞこれこれうち
あれか
なるほどこれは思わせぶりな態度ですよ今
ドキッとしてるよ
こういうテクニックもあるよというのを
見せたかった見つけたです
穴入れるよりここ狙った方が
落とせるよっていうのを
偶然起こしましたトミカのカービィ可愛く
ない
可愛いちょっとこれ狙っていきます
純粋に欲しいの方向で
全然ダメだな
いやー重心取られてない
どう
見てこれ雨3つついてんだよ
ゴムほらなるほどこっちはさ1個やっぱ
ないとでこっちも見てみよう1個ないん
ですよやっぱりこれこれこっちもないと
これ古代見えたねこれです
マジで
はいはいはいはいはいはいあーこれダメだ
ねこれ
[音楽]
軽いんだろうね
ゲットです
これはダメです
行きます
どう
ひっくり返せばいけそうなんだ
[音楽]
[拍手]
前に進むしかない
[音楽]
2個目それでいこうちょっと勘弁してよ
マジで普通に渋い
逆にね
[音楽]
えでもこれさ逆にじゃない
はいなんか
[音楽]
何を信じればいい
はいはいあとひっくり返したらもうこれ
[音楽]
次行きましょうか
ちょっとさ俺思ったんですけど
軽すぎて逆に難しい気がした今ごめん
なさいカービィで行きます
8個目あもう浮いてる浮いてるって
Ok落ちないで2個行け
[音楽]
ゲットしました
ねこれ俺がこういうちっちゃいのちょっと
苦手なのもありましたね最高に可愛いな
許しましょう
じゃあ次はあーにゃ取りに行きましょう
いやーこういう人気キャラこそ難しい気が
するんだよなぁ
そうだけど近づきましたOkOk
戻りました
[音楽]
両替シートを行いますか
倒したらいけそうじゃない
はいはいこれでどう
なりますか
それでいいんじゃないかなどう
思います
まずい気がしてきたあぶねー
やばいやばい
いいんじゃないその位置をさすがにうわぁ
これは言ったでしょ
よし
取れましたいやーでもこのサイズ
ぬいぐるみにしては妥当な金額な気がし
ます
本当に難しいです次行きましょう7段目
行きます
OkOkごめんごめん
短かったこんなもんでしょう
それも攻めすぎ
どれくらい動かせないはいこれをちまちま
とやっていくタイプなんでお金はかかる
けど着実に進めますそれでいいはいはい
はいはい
いいですね
もう確実には言ってんだけどなぁ
はいここで1万円使い切りました
[拍手]
もうちょっと早く取れたらだいぶ変わって
たと思うんですけども1万円頂いて今6台
平均です両替してきます両替してきました
じゃあ10,100円目です
はい入った入った
グイグイグイ
やりすぎたね
どう見ても
でも
いやいや
絶対入ってなかった
入ってるって
いやもう入ってるけどいや
めっちゃいい人だったのになんか下がっ
てるなこれはミスだ俺のちょっとねこう
向けるのが早すぎた
学校なってたんですよ気づいたらこの位置
に
あーやっと取れました
やっぱこうだんだん縦になってるんです
けど気づいたら横になってて押したら取れ
ました
地獄のような金額つぎ込んだよすみっコ
ぐらし人気だからまあしゃあないでしょう
次いきます次は
これは同じやつだなこっちの方が近いので
こっちにします行くよメロンパンナちゃん
持ってるねこれこれもなかなか体も大きい
まずしっかり
奥にあると
跳ねるよ
こうやって
やつれたが
結構入った
あーやばいそのまま
びっくりしたアンパンマン取りました9代
目です
カービィとアーニャこれはでも
カービィの方が小さくて動かしやすいと
思うんですけども落ちるところまでの距離
が結構あるんですよ一方アーニャは大きい
んですけども落ちるまでの距離がカービィ
より2倍ぐらい小さいので行きます
OK最高です
こっちじゃないかな思ったより短いねこれ
えーカービンにします
そうだ俺はそれを求めていたそして
だいぶ前来たよあと気持ちだけ気持ちいい
はいはいはいはい
プンプンツ入ったOk
あとはもうトントントントントントントン
結構かかりましたね最初ちょっとアーニャ
の方触っちゃったんでそこでかさんじゃい
ましたはい続いてはこちらポムポム
ポムポムポム大丈夫これだいぶ圧力かかっ
てますけども
ちょっと待ってやばいやばい
まあまあまだオッケーオッケー
でかいこれはあともうボンボンボムで
終わりよこれ
あるか
うわあああすごい
いやーいろいろと苦しいが
そこをなんとか
ここで2万円使いました2枚目今9台制覇
してますねちょっとどこかで窓稼げるよう
に頑張って早く取りますでは2万100円
目いきますこれモンスターもいけそうじゃ
ないもうシンプルに行くね
行います
早い早い早い早いよし取れました
マッケンジです
どんどん行きましょう11代目シナモン
ロールタン
持ってください
もう全部グッと行ってこれでどれぐらい
動くかじゃないかなOkOkOkOkOk
OkOkなるべく動けばいける
可愛い
いいんじゃないのいいんじゃないの
OKシナモンロールさんゲットです早い
やっぱりアームが強いのかもしれない
意外と大きい方が皆さん狙いドックかも
しれないですねちょっとどんどん行き
ましょう12台目アーニャ行きます2種類
ありますねちょっと
薄めのなんかアニメっぽい方と結構濃い
感じの体が平たい方が取りやすいもので
こっちで行きましょうかいやこれは多分
基本頭狙いでいいんですよ多分
なるほどなるほどこれで傾いて前コイン
オッケー前来た
行いますか
得意なのかもしれないこの子行きます
いやー結構丸いからこれはもう結構
あれ1回200円なのやばい2倍の金額が
かかるということかでもこれ結構真っ向
勝負っぽいんでシンプルに
シンプルにいけそうじゃねこれ
なるほど一発一発の重みが違う風よこれ
見せれないよ
200円でそれは重いって
動画をキープを行いますか
わいい次行きましょう14代目マリオの
キノコですうわーこれも1回200円か
いや1回200円の重みマジでやばいんだ
よなきのこは普通にもうこれだってさ頭
持てばさ行けるんじゃね
[音楽]
滑るタイプね
OKOKOK
いい感じかも
きのこっていう形が非常にいやらしい性的
な意味で
毒キノコ
毒キノコ毒キノコとうわ
[音楽]
ぁ
なるほど可愛い結構俺の趣味に刺さってる
んだけど
えーっと3万円なくなりました200円
コーナーで結構お金も
減った感じだったのでここから頑張ります
行け行け行け行け行けうわー
よしそれはさぁ行くよ
何が起きたこれビッグチャンス
よしよしはいはいはいはい取れました俺
です
か
早いカップ出てる取れました
18代目です
ここをいかに早く片付けられるかが勝負の
分かれ道だと俺思ってるぜいきます
ちょっとでもこっちでも
もうちょっと
めっちゃ早いよマリオ取りました次です
また200円コーナーちょっと見覚えの
あるやつがいるんですけども多分大丈夫だ
と思います行きますすごいこれ久々にこれ
見た500円入れたら3回できます今まで
500円入れて3回できるのなかったんで
ここでちょっとお金はなるべくセーブし
たいです行くぜー
あーこっちです
うわーどうも
よしよしよし
離しちゃった
ちょっと待ってちょっと待ってちょっと
待ってちょっと待ってくれよ
すぐすぐ
早く行ってくれよ
はい5万円突破しました200円の台が
結構すごいペースでお金がなくなってって
これも今もう4700円使ってますもう
勝負できる位置なので早く取りたい頑張り
ます
5200円目で取れました
20代目ですカービィいきましょう
ちょっと勉強してるやつにしよう
[拍手]
これは
完全に
おいおいなんでだよこれは来たでしょ
おい
これじゃないよ
はいというわけで20代制覇しました
どんどん取っていきましょうもうそこで
行こう21台目
やばいこれ
おーい
ゲットだぜ一発で取ります
[音楽]
[拍手]
じゃあちょっとこれで100円使います
悟空ゲットだぜ25代目です
バッチリですOKメロンパンナちゃん
ゲット
よっしゃドンキーコングゲット28台目
ですなるほど
あるよお
[拍手]
じいちゃんママゲット
誰もいなくなっちゃう
マジで全員ワイプアウト
[音楽]
です30代目ですもちろんこれは
ちっちゃい子に行きますよ
ね
どう
強さ
よしよしよしよしよしよしよしバトル
キングドラゴンゲットです31代目行き
ます
おっとマヨネーズ大臣ゲットです
黒馬バドレックス取りましたなんと5万円
使うのにぴったり3時間ぐらい今時間が
経過してますやっぱちっちゃいのは取り
やすい
のでちょっと頑張って急いで取っていき
たいと思います
果たして何円になるのでしょうか
一気に3個取れましたかわいいちいかは
どっちに倒れるかによって世界変わるやつ
だ
やらかしの中のやらかしまで
気合で何とかしてくれいやあるか
[拍手]
待って待ってそれはやばいどうするどう
するどうするこっち側にビーって行って
オッケー待ってやばいぞ行くぞ
よしよしよしよしルフィー取れました全然
違うでしょ35代目いくぜ
ゴーイエスイエス
高田クリニック
めっちゃ可愛いんだけどマイメロちゃん
ゲットしました俺ねロイドさん好きなんだ
よねやばい
ロイトさんだねはいというわけで小さい台
はコンプリートしました結構
負けたと思いますよ時間ただここから結構
大型のやつだったりとかちょっとクレーン
ゲームじゃないんですけどもこれも一応
トレードして100台の中に入ってるので
それをやっていきたいと思いますいやもう
俺これね結構
やった取れたでも
全部欲しくなってきちゃった
まこれぐらいにしといてやりますか
なるべく取りました次行きましょう38台
目ですスイカの窓口収納ボックスこの
クレーンゲームは1回じゃ取れないやつ
結構時間かけてちまちま動かすやつなんで
こうやって最初から大失敗だよこれぐらい
かな
やりすぎだから
入れて
ちょっとずつ上下で動かしてるみたいな
感じですほらちょっと前出たでしょで
ちょっとずつ動かしとくやつです
頑張ります
牧場の右腕見せます
[拍手]
これは次行きましょう39代目また同じ
タイプのやつです
終了しました39台
停車してますどんどんやっていきましょう
ありがとうございます
よしよしよしよしサンリオキャラクターズ
二段収納ボックスゲットです
可愛いやつこそ難しいね次行きましょう
リュックですね行こうかこの台で40代目
ですこれ何を狙えばいいんだ
浮いたらマジででかいよ両方
[音楽]
っぽいね
終わりなるべく動いて
シビアだな
落ちろ
よしよしよしアンハサウェイのリュック
ゲットしましたもう一台もこれ同じ
リュックなんですけどお一人様1個までだ
から次の健介の分ありがとうございます
皆さん41代目です
よまずはしっかり中心を狙って両方
しっかり動かしていくこれがポイントです
これが良くない例ですねこれですねもう
結構ど真ん中ドアみたいな
さっきまで学んだのは片方を落とせば
勢いで落ちることを私は分かっております
のであーやばい
やっぱこのバウンドを使って
ボヨンとちょっとだけ前に出たと思いたい
絶妙なラインで行く
確実に次とりますありがとうございます
ありがとうございますその2ゲットしまし
たうますぎる学習能力あるね
行きましょう次42代目調子乗った
いやなんかその動かし方ねはい通りです
7万円終わりました7万円使って今42台
制覇してますいやもうちょい下げたいな
頑張ります
もうちょい
この瞬間だったお願いしますありがとう
ございます違うゲットしましたいや
むずかった43代目同じちーかわです
44代目ですメロちゃん行くよ
動いてるね
[音楽]
行います
ありがとうございます
[音楽]
マイメロちゃん取れましたなかなか
ちょっと難しくて最後店員さんのヘルプが
入りましたけども無事取れました次行き
ます45代目行きますなんか俺この子の
スタンプ持ってるな
あと頭戻せば
行いますか
やばいやばい事が起きてるこれ
よしよしそれでいい
それはもう限界かな
いい感じですか
ガッツポーズしてくれてますあとはもう
押せ押せどんどんな気がするけど
取れました
難しかった46代目ワンワン行きます行く
ぜまだ
首根っこを掴みます
逆にどうしよう
OKOK
あとは
貴様ガチコンすればもう
ずれちゃった
戻ったね戻ってる戻ってるやべえどう
しよう8万円
終了しました8万円の結果今46台取れて
ますワンちゃん20万円切れそうな勢いで
ねちょっとなるべく最短ルート最安値で
取っていきたいと思います頑張ります
行いますかいやー
難しかった
めっちゃ時間かかった47代目千葉県いき
ますちょっとわんわんが続くないや俺これ
難しい
よしよしまずはしっかり動かしていく
出だしはいいんだよね
両替シートに行いますかはいはいはい
行いますか
ここからですか
行いました
[音楽]
この
瞬間だった
さっきの経験を生かして早くなりました次
48台目48代目
千葉はいきますこっちにやることが大事
もうこれワンちゃんあるよ
チワワそれました49代目行きます
LINEスタンプでよく見るウサギ中心と
なるなるほど
やったドラゴンゲットだぜ50代目です
ようやく折り返しですねちょっとこのクマ
ちゃん取りたいと思います
久々にシンプルなやつが来たぞ
近づけばOk
Googleよし
行いますか
行います
か
これで50代終了です
ようやく半分来ました50代やったところ
時間が5時間半かかりましたさすがに5
時間半ぶっ通しでクレーンゲームやったら
ちょっとあの頭がおかしくなってきたと
いうか若干自分が誰かわからないクレーン
ゲームとは何か自分の生きる意味
けいすけの家族全く何が何だか分からなく
なってきました
折り返しということでここからまた気を
引き締めて頑張っていこうと思います51
代目このおにぎり持ったにゃんこよろしく
お願いします
[音楽]
当たった
はい5時間40分にして9万円使いました
さすがにゲーセンで9万円使ったことは
ないです優越感そして謎の罪悪感とともに
私はまだまだクレーンゲームしていきたい
と思います
おにぎりおにぎりおにぎり
おにぎり
おにぎりを取れました52代目ブルーナ
アニマルなんかミッフィーぽいやつ行き
ますなんか
掴み
[音楽]
ます
重たいな
なるほどなるほど
バズライトイヤー取りました54台目猫
ちゃん行きます
なるほど頭もちょっと出します
OK作戦
やりたいと
[音楽]
思います
かあとは脳天堂
スーパーマリオブラザーズ絶対違う55代
目
ドラゴンズ
いやまだ察しちゃいけないなこれ
刺します
よしメタルスライム取れました56代目
サメちゃん行きますなんか多分この
アルミ玉をちょっとずつ前に出せばゲット
できるというやつですいきます
めっちゃ動いたけどね
行います57台目メンダコちゃん行きます
[音楽]
次かな
いややばいやばいやばいやばいわめっちゃ
上手くなった
すごかったノーミスじゃない脳みそだった
よ
ゲットしましたやっぱりやれば上手くなる
気がした例えば苦手なクレーンゲームは
絶対あるんですけど得意なやつがなんか
確実に弱くなっちゃってる気がする58台
目です
チェーンソーマンですね
碇シンジ取りに行きますよ
これだけマキマさんに書いてもらっていい
ですか前髪が若干上がってましたがまきま
さんで行かせていただきます
待ってやばいいや
遊べるなー結構いい感じじゃない
泣きました
[音楽]
待って待って本当に渋い
頼む頼むあいいんじゃないよしよっしゃー
やっば
えっ3000円ぐらい行ったけど59台目
ですうわぁわんわんとクマがいるんです
けど
犬の方が好きなのでワンワン行きます
ちなみに今入れてるのと合わせて400円
使ったら10万円です4回で取れるかな
いくぜ
めっちゃいい感じ全然そんなことなかった
もうどこ取られてるかわからんラスト
100円これやば10万円です
[音楽]
10万円使いました冷戦で10万円使った
ことある
なかなかね
精神状態がね歪んでくるあでも折り返し
地点にはいるからまあまあ20万以内に
収めたいところであります
頑張ります10万100円おいマイメロ
あーちょっとずれたかな
頼む
よっしゃー早かったワンワンゲットです先
行きましょう60代目です次はちょっと
クレーンゲームとは違うんですけどもこれ
チップスターのなんかゲームですねコイン
を入れてゲームスタートというこういうの
があるんですけどこれで
黄色い部分を狙うとボタンパンって押すと
多分下がってくるのでこの黄色いとこを
狙って当てれば景品ゲットと行きます60
代目
余裕でしょ
地獄のような難しかった
ちょっと待って
どう今までダメえっクレーンゲームじゃ
ないので時間取りたくない
ゲット今何が起きた
振動で倒れたんじゃないですか
61台目バブルキャッチャー俺の予想だと
感じる多分行きますよ
ボタン押してから若干ラグいのが難しい
取れました62台目ですポテチ
[音楽]
動物ゲット64台目
猫ちゃんちょっとだけ寝込みがある方が
いいから
[音楽]
ゲット65代目これはイージーぽいけどな
取れました
数的に1個100円ぐらいですかねゲット
です66台目チョコパイ帰ります
[音楽]
でしたね
箱のこの隙間に挟んでゲットです普通7代
目ですなんと100円で5プレイこんな
機会もあるのかいいゲーセンだな1回目
行きます
[音楽]
よしよしよし
なんだこの紙マシーンは
全然ダメだラスト1回です
[音楽]
いやーまず気持ちいいなこれ
うわーすごい
結構取れた100円でこの量だと思う
プラスな気がするんだけどこういうのがあ
るってことですね気持ちいい気持ちいい
68台目メルティーこの手のやつ結構時間
かかるじゃん多分両替機
いやそこ引っかかる
68台目で11万円使いましたお菓子
ゾーンで結構簡単に取れたのが多かったの
で割と抑えられてます頑張ります
か
取れました今までやってきた中で一番何を
すればいいかわかんなかった69代目トム
とジェリーのチョコレートいやさっきと
比べたらマジでやりやすい
両替地域
ごめんなさい
ちょうどゼリーのチョコレートゲットです
70代目バカでかいガーナがありますね
これは俺の得意なやつだと思いたいぜ
そうだろう
よしよしよし
[音楽]
この集会なんて
でかいから取れました次行きましょうと
いうわけで70代戦始まりました
さあ残るところこのゲームセンターには
クレーンゲームあと30代となりました
ですがご覧くださいここからはもう見て見
てもここからはフィギュアですよ
フィギュア参りましたはいはい戦ってない
そうですクレーンゲームお菓子とか
ぬいぐるみとかももちろん難しいんです
けどもフィギュアがマジで難しい重いん
ですよそもそもここからかなり難易度が
あったかくなると思いますあと30代
頑張ります71代目行きます
ヘブンバーンズレッドピングの子が可愛い
ので君を狙いに行こうかな
話すなそれだよ
全然違う
やったーいやいや取れました
めっちゃかかったな多分
意外と難しいなこのタイプも72代目
セブンティーンの缶バッジ行きますみんな
イケメンだなどうやって取る
はい11万円終わりましたこういう小物系
とかも結構難しいですね12万100円目
いきます
よっしゃー
オッケーオッケーさすがに行ったでしょお
願いしますお願いしますよありがとう
ございますゲットですよし73台目
ビーバーサのくまさん行きます
早い
これはどうなるんでしょうか
いいですかありがとうございます
74代目東京リベンジャーズちふゆ狙いに
行きます
すぐ取れる200円で取れました
ありがとうございます75代目次は直
キット着るやつですかねいやもう
いらっしゃいますよだったら夜さん狙いに
行こううわなるほど
うわおしいこれおもろいなあれ
めっちゃセンサー
やったー
ゲットしました結構難しかったと思いまし
たけど意外と早く行きました76代目ワン
ピースのワンダーついにフィギュアゾーン
に来ましたいい出だしか
動いた動いた
いいのかなよしよしよしあと向き変える
だけな気がする
あーなんかやばいことになってるあー
あー
ワンピースのパンダちゃん取れました
おっぱいでかやっぱちょっと難易度高い
ですね取れることはわかったのでどんどん
取っていきます77代目引き続きワン
ピースのキャロットちゃんはこっちも
可愛いな一番下の同じ感じだと思うはい
まずはサクッと動かしていく
戻っちゃった戻った
キャロットちゃんゲットですさあ
フィギュア2個を取りましたけども結構む
ずいなーどんどん行きましょう78台目
ワンピーストラファルガールローいきます
ワンピースのことは詳しくおりませんが
人気なことをしてますこれ人気ですよね
人気ですでかいから難しそうだな
これこうじゃないか
[音楽]
取れました
めっちゃかっこいい多分
比較的早い方で撮りたいような気がする次
行きましょう次はウマ娘メジロドーベル
行きますよし何
よしよしよしよしやばい
はい79台目にして13万円使いました
13万100円目です
[拍手]
ね取れました80代目行きます
マチカネタンホイザー
やらかしたやばい
[音楽]
しゃーない
行かせていただきます
めっちゃ可愛いいやーこれ
むずかったなぁ81台目開くからのマグ
カップ持っていきましょう
動かせばあるはい動きましたもう
詰んで終わりだよお前お前は終わったぜ
これで落ちなかったらやばい
[音楽]
カップ取れました次次はイラストマーカー
ペンです
めっちゃ綺麗また上下に動かして前に出し
たやつです頑張ります82台目行きます
取れました思ったすごい見てくださいこれ
すげー
めっちゃペン入ってるこれは普通に嬉しい
ねイラストマー画面ゲットです83代目
メタルスライムのマグカップ行きます
14万円分使い終わりましたこのスライム
がマジで難しいドツボにはまってる
14万100円目でいきます
84台目なんかボディケアのマッサージ機
かな狙ってきます天才
でも変態
[音楽]
[拍手]
これはヤバすぎた
泣かないでください
代目チョキチョキですエンダードラゴン
狙っていきます
無理無理無理これもうやばい
これは
店員さんこれはこれあの
切ります
次も職種です86台目じゃ次の
チョキチョキはレンジ狙います
ゲットしました次はいというわけで次は
87代目こちら
be:FIRSTのクマなんですけども見
てください
来ました1回200円コース早めに
繰り出しますいっぱい200円だから重荷
がやばい
あめっちゃ動くでも
[拍手]
簡単な設定なのかな1回200円1回
200円でミスったのやばい
はいここで15終わりました
いやこの200円ゾーンがまだ来て一緒隣
見てくださいこれ
杉山200円だこれ
15万100円目いきます
やっちまったよしよしやだー400円
騎士飛んじゃった
間違えた
600円
もうねやり続けて本当に集中力ない俺何回
やったんだろう
よしよし次で刺す
おやすみ
ゲットしました次88台目ビーファースト
次はピンクのクマさんですねいきましょう
か
めっちゃ強いわこれいや見た見た
めっちゃ動いたよ
動く動く動く
戻った戻った200円入れて戻った
よっしゃーピンクのクマちゃん取れました
いや200円ゾーンはメンタルがマジで
きつい
晩飯で200円なくなると相当つらいです
けどめっちゃ可愛いよし次行きましょう
89台目このちっちゃいアーニャ狙います
行くます
おっとなかなか重い
握りしめろ
でもなんか反応した
松山まじやばいマジやばいやばい
[音楽]
なやばい
[笑い]
うわ
ぁやばいやばい無理か
よっしゃー
[音楽]
[拍手]
取れました今のところ一番かかった気がし
ますこれ最高級ですはいここで16万円
使いました
戦慄のアーニャに相当持ってかれました
けれども16万円使って90代目に来まし
たクッションみたいなやつかな取って
いこうと思います90代目この手のやつは
もう
あれ届いてないいや待ってマジで今心持っ
てかれてる普通に
どうなってんのこれ見てこれ見える
バランスがやばいもう奇跡のバランスまで
いやもうさすがに行った
狙い通りこの
瞬間ドキドキだね
[音楽]
軽いから
難しかったわ重さがないからパーンって
落ちないからめっちゃギリギリまで粘られ
ましたけどゲットですというわけでしまし
たさあ残すところあと10台フィギュアな
ので更に難しくなると思われます
果たして全て制覇するのに何円かかるの
でしょうか俺の体力はもう
0です91代目ONEPIECE
トラファルガーロードフィギュアがあるん
でこれ狙います
久々にストレートかこれ
困りますなるほどなるほど
だいぶ来た
次の戦略も考えておこう
ドキドキしたね
[音楽]
トラファルガーローをゲットしました割と
早く行けたぞ次92台目5等分の花嫁より
中のいつきちゃんチャンネル
行きますあやばい
まずは顔に度数大事な挨拶です
5等分の花嫁ゲットです93代目リコリス
リコイル人気アニメですねこれはまた
ゲットするのが難しい93年目行きます
OK
最高のスタートだこれ
[拍手]
[音楽]
94台目ヒロアカビリを行きます
OKよく入ったなぁ
95代目ヒロアカジローきかちゃん
しっかり取っていきましょう17万円
突破しましたあと3万円でしょなんとか
20万円以内に抑えたい頑張ります
同じサイズなのにやっぱり
沼と全然
抜け出せなくなりますねこれがフィギュア
のボックスの恐怖ですね次96台目東京
リベンジャーズ
ゲットしましたさあ次です97台目
ゴールデンカムイの人主人公ですねほぼ
健介
めちゃくちゃいいね
ゲットしましたもうむずすぎて本当に全く
動かなくなるんですよ次行きましょう98
台目うる星やつらのラムちゃんかわいい
ですね
ラスト3つないとめちゃくちゃ高いんで
ちょっとここからは最上級コースな気がし
ます頑張ります98試合目行きますか
めっちゃ
可愛いラムちゃん撮れましたよしあと2個
です99台目青春バトルはバニーガール
先輩に夢を見ないし桜島麻衣先輩です
よろしくお願いします行きますよ
こんなもんですか
これやばいでしょクオリティ黒島マイ先輩
服がもうやばさあ残すところあと1台最後
はサイズがもう狂っておりますベムちゃん
超特大サイズ和風メイドバージョンですね
レムちゃん行こうと思います
はいどんぐらい動くかなあー
意外と動くぞこれ今ので18万円使いまし
た
これね2万円使わなければ20万以内で
クリアできますのでちょっといかにこれ
早く食べるかと思いますいやーこれやばい
な
可愛いねとってもラスボスにふさわしい
みたいにしてる
入ってないのそれおいおいおいおいおい
浅いねごめんごめん
バグっちゃってる俺もやばい早く
終わらせたくてマジできついもうそろそろ
進めたいから一回安牌狙います
よしよしよしよしよしよし
入れ入れ入れ
よっしゃーマックスだこれも最大
火力さっきの
必ず左右するよ
ねレブちゃん取りました
全体性
お疲れ様です
楽しいんですけど足がきついのと
ぬまった時のお金の溶けてくる感がすごい
つらかったです
めっちゃ見て最後超かわいいよ
[音楽]
制覇しました
帰りましょう
[音楽]
というわけで
ルームセンターにあったクレーンゲーム全
大制覇してきました
100台近く100台近くクレーンゲーム
やって19万ぐらいかかってますね100
台で19万でしょまあまあだいたい平均1
台2000円ぐらいかければ取れるよって
いう感じなのは分かりましたけど全然値段
違いますからねなんかすごい安く取れるの
もあれば
めっちゃくちゃすごい値段かかったやつも
ありましたので僕が下手
だったら今回の検証ですそういう結果が出
たということでお伝えしておきます
マジで取れなくなるから本当に欲しい時は
早めに店員さんを呼ぶのがちょっと
ポイントな気がしましたクレーンゲーム
最高
[音楽]